maman était en bonne santé elle avait de
légers troubles cognitifs dire des
petites pertes de mémoire et un tout
début d'alzheimer mais vraiment tout
début et elle et elle marche elle est
autonome elle n'était pas un continent
tels étaient en bonne santé voilà
pourquoi elle avait intégré cet
établissement alors passe comme elle a
ses petits troubles cognitifs on avait
peur de la laisser ça là la maison
d'accord allez trouver une structure
avec du personnel à domicile et on
m'avait conseillé j'avais pas trouver le
personnel à domicile tout de suite parce
qu'il fallait des gens de confiance si
on m'avait dit écoute pendant cette
petite phrase tu peux la mettre
puisqu'elle s'était cassé le col du
fémur et elle avait été en maison de
rééducation une maison de soins de suite
et c'est la maison de soins de soins de
suite qui m'avait dit mais tu es là
derrière pendant quelques mois le temps
que vous mettiez en place toute
l'infrastructure vous payé combien pour
moi pas moi plusieurs milliers d'euros
aux alentours de 6 me
message à m c'est énorme
donc là bon marché au coup de pouce
alors ça a démarré très rapidement j'ai
commencé à me rendre compte que maman
perdait un petit peu sa motivation
parlait pas être est un peu frustré et
quelques semaines après son entrée
c'était le début de confinement d'accord
que ça y tient un problème on pouvait
pas l'avoir normalement on devait
communiquer en fait ce time soit disant
que le personnel tous les jours nous
offrait le temps de parole de deux
minutes ou 3 minutes avec nos parents
mais c'était plutôt une fois par semaine
et on me téléphone un jour et on me dit
votre mère est tombée elle a beaucoup
saigné sa attaché la moquette
en
fait non mais sa tâche et la moquette et
voilà le mot qui elle est dans sa
énormément saigner j'ai nommé comment ça
elle est tombée quand mayer jeudi mais
vous me l'aviez pas dit mais je lui dis
vous avez fait des points de suture vous
avez fait des radios on m'a répondu on
n'a pas fait de points de suture parce
qu'on est arrivé ça saigne et plus déjà
mais il y avait beaucoup de sang j'ai
dit mais vous avez fait une radio voir
s'il n'y a pas un hématome s'il n'y a
pas un trauma ah ben non
première chose maman éristique cinq mois
il ya eu quatre accidents ensuite
l'ordre confinement on n'avait pas le
droit de la voir mais on se voyait
derrière une glace moi j'étais dehors et
derrière on glass on avait chacun un
masque ma mère était très coquette comme
vous avez pu voir c'était une dame
coquette avec un beau sourire ou bah oui
telle mère telle fille c est donc
l baisse son masque et elle pleure et là
je vois que c'est dans été classée donc
elle avait des trous mais il y avait
plus de dents moment avec des facettes
et il y avait plus d'un aurait défiguré
qui
est là elle pleure et là je me dis j ai
demandé à ce qu'on fout de ses yeux
parce que de la voir comme ça d'un sur
dur et voilà en à moi en à moi donc je
peux pas moi je suis moi même chirurgien
dentiste non même si je ne peux pas
esquissé insupportable de voir ça c'est
insupportable je peux pas expliquer ça
je ne peux l'expliquer que de valeur
donc vous voyez ça vaut lui de vous lui
dites pas oublier que celle fixée mais
qu'est ce qui se passe hélas elle pleure
et à l'arrivée pas s'exprimer à mehdi
chumash comme ça je suis machin je suis
machin je peux pas me regarder dans la
glace chômage et tout ça derrière une
glace donc moi je vais je vais porter
plainte je discute avant vous avez une
main quand j'ai fait nos coûts en main
courante non mais enfin quand je dis que
je portais plainte je vais me plaindre
auprès des dirigeants et des soignants
je dis que c'est inadmissible je demande
d explication aucune explication j'exige
d'avoir accès à sa chambre pour pouvoir
me faire des soins pour pas la laisser
comme ça donc j'ai accès à la chambre et
là je vois que sa bouche était dans un
état déplorable
je prends des empreintes jumain
provisoire et après je demande à la
faire sortir pour la soigner au cas
d'option et lorsque j'ai demandé à la
faire sortir j'ai vu que ma mère n'avait
plus du tout les mêmes réflexes déjà
qu'elle marchait beaucoup moins bien et
qu'elle était hagard qu'elle était
perdue et qu'elle avait son image qui
était complètement détériorés c'est
important pour les personnes âgées de
rester joli village l'avoir plus
alémanique on la voyait elle était
vraiment à l'essai et pas maquillée ni
rui voyez c'est une belle famille 88 ans
sur ces territoires
donc je l'emmène au cabinet je lui
procure des soins et je préviens les
pattes que je la ramène vers 18 heures
avant le repas on arrive en voiture et
là il ya personne pour recevoir ma mère
patrie est-ce rien j'étais avec une amie
qui peut même la tester on trouve une
chaise roulante sur laquelle n'y avait
même pas les repose pieds dont moi
j'étais accroupi à 4 pas à lui tenir les
pieds pour pas que ses pieds traîne le
sol pour la monter dans sa chambre et la
personne nous accueille ça c'était le
deuxième incident troisième incident et
et ma mère parlait de moi je n'avais pas
exactement comment il s'était cassé les
dents j'ai essayé de savoir qu'on m'a
pas dit moi je pense que c'est un manque
d'hygiène ils n'ont pas dû lui laver les
dents ils ont dû lui donner des choses
très sucrée elle devait pas beaucoup
boire parce qu'elle avait l'air
déshydraté également je précisais je
demandais à ce qu'on met de l'eau est là
elle devait pas beaucoup voir donc du
coup il y avait une fermentation plus
importante dans la cavité buccale et ça
fait une carie décarie flambante et elle
a dû croquer quelque chose ça casse et
elle n'a pas pu me dire elle avait mal
ça lui blessé l'intérieur des joues et
ils n'ont rien fait ils ne m'en avait
pas parlé c'est honteux troisième
incident en début juillet on m'appelle
un dimanche vers 12h45 et on me dit
votre maman est tombé jeudi allaient
tomber qu'est ce qui s'est passé elle
est tombée quand mon dieu il tombait
hier il ya peut-être une suspicion de
fracture j'ai une suspicion de fracture
j'arrive en plus j'avais précisé j'avais
six pull et lorsque je les ai fait cette
admission j'étais pétrifiée parce que
pour moi on met pas les parents dans des
dans des maisons on les garde à la
maison j'ai toujours promis qu'on garde
à la maison je faisais tout pour la
garder la maison et donc je n'y mets à
lui tombé quand elle est tombée hier
julie elle est tombée hier samedi ils
vous me prévenez dimanche à 12h45 d'une
suspicion de fracture et on dit oui bah
on l'a couché là même à l'épi ce matin
bas mal encore mal j'arrive je vois ma
mère qui était habillé donc elle n'avait
pas sa tenue du coucher c'est à dire
elle n'était pas en pyjama donc ils
avaient déjà mobilisé il avait mobilisé
l'épaule le bras pour la mettre en
pyjama il l'avait remobiliser pour la
rhabiller hélas le
l'infirmier me dit
oui on pense qu'à une suspicion de
fracture à l'épaule et gym on va aller à
l'hôpital donc on part elle était juste
à l'ehpad à côté à boulogne le corbusier
donc on part en ambulance à l'hôpital la
l'hôpital en pleine période de vide 6h
ma mère toute seule dans les couloirs et
moi dehors j'avais pas loin d'être à
côté l'enfer est au bout de six heures
je la retrouve ma fille m'avait rejoint
elle était complètement prostrée elle
savait pas ce qui s'était passé elle
était dans un couloir sur un brancard
toute seule et elle avait sa main avec
un dujarrier c'est une attelle de
contention qui laisse la main comme ça
et elle savait pas où elle était et elle
parlait plus et la seule chose qu'il
disait maman tu m'as montre c'est tout
parce que c'était une attache à cette
montre on repart en a ri et je demande à
l'hôpital s'ils pouvaient lagarde est
hospitalisé il me dit non en pleine
période de kovy d'une dame âgée vaut
mieux car en tournant les pages je
retourne à l'ehpad l'été huit heures du
soir maman était absolument pannetier et
donc je demande à rester à passer la
nuit à côté d'elle on dit non jeudi
savez moi je peux m'asseoir partir je
lui donne la main ce que je veut cibler
la main elle est perdue elle fleure al
amal ont dit non je dis ok mais tu es
des barrières sur le lumie pour pas
qu'elle tombe parce qu'elle peut
rechuter ont dit non elle avait chuté
comment on ne s'est jamais décès jamais
assez maladroit préalablement la chute
est jamais jamais dès la chute deux fois
on ne sait pas comment on sait pas
comment et à chaque fois c'est des
chutes forte puisque l souvient tuera ça
sonne et ska une épaule et à la dernière
chute qui est fatal donc on va y venir
et donc on me refuse mais des barrières
qui est le propre de la sécurité en me
disant que elle risque de l'enjamber par
une dame de stage à la enjambé la
barrière on je demande à ce qu'on mette
un matelas le long du lit si jamais elle
roule pour qu'elle tombe sur matelas on
refuse et on dit de partir manu militari
ont dit vous partez le lan moi j'étais
mortifié maman pleurer andy me laisse
pas me laisse pas je pouvais rien faire
d'autre le lendemain matin j'arrive à 10
heures sans prévenir et je vois ma mère
dans le couloir qui avait alors pour la
prescription médicale de l'hôpital
disait il ne faut absolument pas un
membre passé doit être en contentieux
sans envie sans bouger durant des
semaines voire un mois joie ma mère à
qui on avait mis un petit t-shirt
qu'avait le dujarrier qui était mal
repositionner et qui tenait avec sa main
sa petite canne
jure le chemin ce bandage je vais
chercher un kiné genou qu'est ce que
c'est que ça et là on me dit ah mais
votre maman a enlevé son attelle gimmi
c'est impossible puisque la tâche et
dans le dos quel à la main droite
qu'elle ait droit tient elle peut pas
faire ça si c'est un peu ce type c'est
vous et puis je lui dis au pire si elle
avait enlevé la tél oui si je veux bien
vous croire elle n'aurait pas mis petit
short et tee-shirt et d'un retrait donc
on dit ah bah non on a dû la lave et
donc ça veut dire comme faute un membres
cassés on l'a mobilisés on ya ses amphis
mais un petit chat c'est dramatique et
les souffrances a vraiment rebondi après
sur quelque chose aisée parce qu'après
on va voir on va parler on va parler du
quatrième accident qui est malade et la
talent va en parler on se tape rugby
voilà c'est vraiment important alors là
c'est
avec votre accord les menaces que vous
avez reçus aujourd'hui par téléphone
c'est ça voilà donc aujourd'hui vous
avez reçu des mails à écouter en train
d'être au téléphone on téléphone à mon
cabinet dentaire c'est mon assistante
qui décroche et on lui dit vous dire
madame schwarz sur un ton très véhément
monsieur numéro inconnu qu'elle se taise
et qu'elle arrête de parler de tout ça
et d'orpea mon assistant dès aujourd'hui
à 16h15 incroyable mon assistant dit
mais vous étiez monsieur qu'est ce que
c'est il a raccroché elle a intérêt de
se taire et il a raccroché donc là on
voit vraiment qu'orpea est prêt à tout
si ça va on avait parlé des 15 millions
d'euros là on parle de menaces
d'intimidation exactement de menaces
d'intimidation vous avez porté plainte
alors j'avais fait une main courante en
décembre 2020
absurde je me suis occupé de ma mère et
je souhaitais la maintenir en vie mais
je vais porter plainte alors accepter la
quatrième qui est alors la quatrième qui
est dramatique donc maman trois semaines
après on appelle six heures après sa
chute pour me dire votre moment il pas
bien ah bon elle est tombée auquel
j'arrive et là je la trouve gisante avec
une tête moribonde elle était en
pratiquement à la limite du coma elle
respirait très mal elle gémit sais j'en
ai la chair de poule rien qu'à de dire
ça en fin de compte
il avait elle était tombée dans
l'après-midi laver à 6 puis comme elle
tenait pas sur la chaise et l'avait mise
au lit à six heures du soir on prévient
donc j'ai dit bon ça suffit je prends
l'ambulance et on part aux urgences
d'hôpitaux américains parce que je
savais qu là bas une dame de 88 ans
serait prise en charge tout de suite et
qu'elle passerait pas la nuit dans le
couloir et à l'issue des radios et des
irm fracture de l'épaule pas consolidée
fracture du sternum fracture des côtes
droites et gauches fracture d dorso
lombaire et un énorme hématome gros
comme un oeuf de poule derrière la tête
donc elle était pratiquement mourante
elle est restée un mois hospitalisé avec
des soins très important elle hurlait
sans cesse ils ont été au top et ensuite
le 1er août j'ai fait j'avais la
structure pour l'avoir chez elle
conclusion tout ça a aggravé son
alzheimer il ya eu un syndrome de
glissement hyper rapide et elle ne
marchait plus quelqu'un qui marchait en
rentrant en cinq mois auparavant ne
marchait plus ne pouvait pas se nourrir
toute seule puisqu'elle pouvait pas
bouger le bras et elle a été volontaire
à la lutte et elle a fini sans pouvoir
déglutir ni aliments ni opa skies haimer
lui avais se perdent le contrôle à duke
l'édition voilà